hola de nuevo muy bien pues vimos lo que
es la inflación y lo que es el índice de
precios al consumidor
ahora que quiero mostrar algunos datos
curiosos e interesantes está hoja es el
comunicado de prensa mensual emitido por
las oficinas de estadísticas del trabajo
esta es la tabla pero te preguntarás qué
es la tabla a bueno la tabla es una es
un resumen de las cosas importantes en
el cambio de porcentaje en el índice de
precios al consumidor urbano ahora se
maneja tabla de precios al consumidor
para todo tipo de consumidor aquí
estamos viendo lo urbano lo que consume
la urbe y bueno a mí me parece mucho más
interesante ver estos detalles que lo
que escuchas normalmente las noticias
los reporteros diciendo o si el ipc
cambio por no sé 0.5 por ciento bla bla
lo que sea y bueno algo también que es
importante mencionar es en estadísticas
del gobierno el ipc que se está
reportando o en cualquier compañía sigue
lo que se está reportando es un cambio
secuencial o un cambio anual entonces
por ejemplo tenemos una nota de prensa
sale una nota de prensa donde se
encabeza con este número
y en las noticias en el periódico en las
noticias tú vas a ver el siguiente
reporte van a decir o en junio 2011 la
inflación en toda la canasta de bienes
bajó por 1.2 por ciento y quizás tus
célebres y digas guau genial no hay
inflación de hecho los precios están
bajando es como una deflación menor pero
hay que tener cuidado a ojo de chícharo
aquí pon atención porque estos precios
están ajustados temporalmente de mayo a
junio así que aquí tengo de mayo a junio
ahora cuando me cuando me refiero
ajustes temporalmente
bueno pues quizás las personas usan más
o menos energía gastan más o menos
energía del mes mayo a junio entonces
todo ellos intentan poner todos estos
datos en lo que son los precios en la
canasta de bienes ya eso me refiero con
ajustes temporales pero como tú puedes
ver aquí de mayo a junio los precios
bajaron según los ajustes temporales sin
embargo siguen altos según los cambios
anuales es decir si tú comparas junio
2010 con junio 2011 aún siguen altos por
3.6 por ciento
al visto desde una manera mensual es más
volátil son ajustes temporales a corto
plazo tenemos más factores de cambio
pero la señal más fuerte aquí son los
cambios anuales esto realmente nos dice
lo que está pasando con la inflación
aunque tal vez alguien quizás se
interese más por el dato mensual porque
esto nos está informando lo que está
pasando en el momento lo que verás con
más frecuencia darán un número de
inflación para todo pero le van a restar
lo que es la comida y la energía
entonces tienes todos los bienes menos
la comida y la energía y esto porque la
comida y la energía dan están en el
reporte de una manera muy volátil estos
datos son muy volátiles entonces por
ejemplo aquí vemos estos datos de la
energía son números gigantes a 20% en la
energía por ejemplo acá tenemos un 35%
en la gasolina y de hecho aquí puedes
observar que la energía la cantidad baja
pero realmente año tras año se eleva y
esto lo que realmente nos da el 3.6 por
ciento entonces si quitamos la energía y
la comida de la ecuación si comparamos
la canasta de bienes menos la comida y
la energía la inflación sólo subió un
1.6 por ciento es bastante
interesante de hecho mirada podemos ver
qué productos y servicios se elevaron su
precio y cuáles bajaron qué interesante
o bajo mira aquí este dato 5.1 por
ciento para vehículos usados y me
sorprende porque es un dato bastante
alto para algo que es usado